which is why over here in addition to
what we call compass bearings that's
what these are compass bearings we also
have true bearings true bearings okay
now true bearings just say look forget
all this northeast Southwest business
let's just use an angle and we measure
everything starting from north okay so
instead of calling that North because
the starting point I'm going to call it
zero okay now therefore if I measure
clockwise around clockwise that would
make this guy 90 this one down here
would be a hundred and eighty and this
one over here would be 270 now it keeps
going what's the what's the largest
angle you would have that indicates a
true bearing a 360 and zero are the same
one which is fine but you wouldn't
really say 360 if you can just say zero
so probably 359 and whatever number of
decimal places because the largest
number you'll get is three digits these
are often called three digit bearings
and in fact to make that official we
actually often write them even when
they're less than three digits we write
them with three digits like that and
like this if you're familiar if you
recall back from when you first
encountered 24-hour time we do the same
thing with that you don't say 700 hours
you say oh 700 hours if you're ever
having to describe that properly okay
one last little thing because they're
called true bearings they often are
written with a T afterwards which
indicates true okay generally speaking
if you see the three digits you know
they're going to be three digit bearings
if you see the T you know they're true
bearings if you want to use super
ultra-safe you put both okay now the
wonderful thing about this is it allows
us to
refer to any direction we like to any
accuracy we like okay so for instance on
this sub-tree berry system
I wouldn't say northeast if I wanted to
go in that direction what would I say
I'd say yeah or or 0:45 okay so let's
actually just put that on here in red
won't put all of them but this is a good
example
I'd say 0:45 true if I wanted to
describe a direction like say oh let's
have a look how about north-northwest
north-northwest look at where it is
think about what angle it would be this
is a bit tricky put your pens down and
look up for a second because are we
better if you look by sorry think by
looking rather than feet by writing at
this point come back to this original
diagram between north and east I'm on
this side sorry between north and west
what's that angle that's 90 so therefore
if I go from North to Northwest that
should be 45 and if I go again it'd be
twenty two point five so each one of
these one two three four they're all two
twenty two point five degrees so if I
wanted north northwest let's come back
to my brain now north northwest should
be 22.5 degrees short of the full
revolution right which is three hundred
and thank you okay so this allows us
much more precision so long as you know
how to read where to start from and
which direction to go in
it's vastly superior cuz you don't have
to worry about which which name refers
to what okay now some people have said
and I think this is fairly valid well
both of these systems have their flaws
both of these systems have their forms
because people know north east south
west very very well if you said to
someone a random angle by 209 degrees
true so well where is that you have to
stop and think for a moment don't you
okay so what we did is even though
these are the two main systems compass
bearings Xiu berries there's a sort of
system which is halfway between the two
okay so it's not a separate one it's a
sort of hybrid if you like draw a third
compass bearing compass rose fulness so
this third one here is a cross between
all the names and all the numbers okay
so again I just want you to mark in the
names of the main compass bearings north
south east west now if I wanted to
describe a spot like say east northeast
east north is let's put it in here just
don't label it because we're going to
call it something different if not this
is quite confusing so what we say is we
start from north and then we use an
angle you can see this is why it's a
partway between we use an angle to go in
the east direction right so we're going
to go this angle here what's the size of
it sixty seven point five
let's suppose it was just a bit off
because just awkward decimals that could
be we start from North let's call it 68
we go 68 degrees so the east side so
where we describe this is ah north 68
degrees east if I wanted say let's have
a look down here let's let's pick a
different random angle over here okay
let's suppose this little angle in here
was 10 degrees just there okay
so we always start from the vertical so
this is going to be from south I haven't
gone to the east have I I've gone to the
west so this will be south 10 degrees
west so what this captures is the
intuition that we know about north east
south west but the accuracy of all of
these numbers it's slightly awkward
because it's like two systems kind of
jammed together but people use this and
you need to be able to interpret it okay
does anyone have any questions about
these all right so you'll be on a note
which one is which by the way that it is
written in exactly the same way that
when you see 12:35 p.m. you know that's
12-hour time because the way that it's
written the format tells you and when
you see 20:47 you know that's 24-hour
time and that's 847 in the evening I
take cause of the way it's written
because of the way it's written you
notice every format sana tells you which
ones which okay